il se veut le chantre de la droite
décomplexée au risque d'être critiqué
sinon rejeté désormais par une partie de
son camp jean françois copé est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous l'ump qui se divise
donc la compétition pour sa présidence
et bien nous en parlerons dans un quart
d'heure avec frédéric dumoulin de l'
agence france-presse notre partenaire et
puis perrine tarneaud nous rejoindra et
vous interrogera sur les passages les
plus personnelles de votre livre
programme donc pas celle sur le racisme
anti blanc ou bien le sort subi par
certains enfants durant le ramadan un
mail et parce qu'ils concernent
notamment votre histoire familiale
les téléspectateurs réagissent c'est
posent leurs questions par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque d'orange
notre autre partenaire les attaques
contre l'exécutif d'abord si vous voulez
bien
jean françois copé je parle d' attaque
car là je constate que les mots sont de
plus en plus fort le mot imposture par
exemple est sorti de votre bouche
puisque vous condamner par avance que
chef de l'état son premier ministre ou
est-ce l'un des effets là encore
peut-être collatéral de la campagne
interne à l'ump a mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec la campagne de l'ump je crois
que en cinq mois
les français sont en train d'ouvrir les
yeux sur ce que nous avions et ou en
particulier avec mes amis dénoncer tout
au long de la campagne sur fond de
françois hollande s'est fait élire sur
une imposture
il a fait croire aux français que
l'essentiel des malheurs notre pays
venait de ce que nicolas sarkozy était à
la tête du pays et il a fait croire que
pour ce qu'il concernait il n'allait pas
augmenter les impôts et qu'il allait en
réalité faire ce que nous ne faisions
pas comme un résultat des courses qu'est
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
a systématiquement supprimés toutes les
mesures excellente que nous avions
prises pense en particulier à la
détaxation des heures supplémentaires
pour les gens qui a du coup
malheureusement ne peuvent plus
maintenant gagner plus en travaillant
plus ou bien encore en supprimant les
allègements de charges patronales quand
on entend un brestois on entend critique
remise en cause des capacités des
compétences presque de la légitimité du
pouvoir et nono
bon écoute et non légitimité la question
de légitimité ne se pose pas il ya
insuffle le suffrage universel s'est
exprimée en revanche pour le reste oui
bien sûr qu'il ya eu mensonge bas enfin
écoutez il ya pas de doute là dessus
vous ou vous avez entendu vous monsieur
hollande annoncé qu'il allait augmenter
de 30 milliards d'euros les impôts en
quatre mois pour matraquer fiscalement
la totalité des français
puis les mensonges ont continué après il
ya encore quinze jours et jean marc
ayrault à la télévision annonce sans
rire que neuf français sur dix ne seront
pas concernés par les hausses d'impôts
vous avez pu constater en tant que
journalistes qu'il avait fait ce qu'on
appelle un mensonge d'état devant des
millions de français
qu'est ce qui se passe la conséquence de
tout ça c'est quoi en quatre mois
c'est toute l'économie française qui est
paralysée moche peut en témoigner un mot
la ville dont je suis maire je rencontre
un entrepreneur un artisan un commerçant
un ménage tous me disent on bouge plus
on et prennent pas on consomme pas on
n'investit pas n'embauchent pas quand
l'arrière du pouvoir ne correspond pas
aux promesses électorales vous parlez
d'un mensonge d'état n'est donc rien a
eu des mensonges d'état sans doute tous
les régimes euros peut-être enfin
jusqu'à un certain point moi j'ai pas le
souvenir que nous n'avons pas de mise en
oeuvre les promesses que nous avions
présenté aux français en 2007 par
exemple rappelez-vous nous avions dit
très clairement que nous allions détaxer
les heures supplémentaires nous l'avons
fait nous avions dit très clairement
nous allions supprimé les droits de
succession nous l'avons fait les
socialistes d'ailleurs l'ont
immédiatement les ont immédiatement
remis nous avons dit que nous allions
autant que possible libérer l'économie
autant qu'on le pouvait on l'a fait nous
allons rien faire face à des crises
successives très douloureuse
je constate aujourd'hui que nous avons
un gouvernement totalement perdue avec
une absence totale de cap stratégique
alors que dresse pas moins qu'il dit ou
regardez les
les enquêtes d'opinion regarder l'état
des français aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
une décision économique est pris d'un
entretien le pouvoir dit qu'il fait à
52,2 chose qu'il a annoncé on va en
parler un peu plus tard si vous voulez
bien jean françois copé mais on a
l'impression quand même que le sentiment
d'unité nationale qui a été évoqué tout
au long du week-end par vous mêmes dans
tous les responsables politiques sur la
question dans les comptes enregistrés
et loin derrière nous les sur la
question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme donné il faut qu est pas donc
là dessus je les dis tout de suite il
est évident que face à une situation
comme celle qui consiste à lutter de
toutes nos forces contre le terrorisme
nous devons être totalement rassemblée
j'aurais aimé d'ailleurs la même unité
nationale lorsqu'elle est arrivée la
tragédie de montauban et de toulouse
vous vous souvenez que les socialistes
en pleine campagne avait tenté de mettre
en cause nos services qui avait pourtant
fait un travail et gréements difficile
jean narration période par exemple ce
mardi solennellement avait voulu d'un
entretien avec les ministres de la
justice de l'intérieur rappelle sa
détermination à lutter contre le
terrorisme et le racisme là vous dites
oui bien sûr rappelons nous seulement on
lit mais on se lasseront le dire
et là la force de conviction pour être
parfois j'écoute et je le souhaite parce
que comme n'associez absolument jamais
l'opposition à rien j'ose espérer qu'il
le prend bien toutes les bonnes
décisions en tout cas il sait je le lui
ai dit c'est mon rôle d'une responsable
du premier parti politique d'opposition
que sur ce sujet il y aura toujours un
rassemblement total en même temps
puisque vous m'interrogez sur ce sujet
et que vous avez noté que monsieur valls
faisait un lien entre les actions
terroristes et à risques d'actions
terroristes et la délinquance que l'on
peut observer dans un certain nombre de
quartiers l'un étant lié à l'autre mais
l'autre n'étant pas heureusement
systématiquement liés alain
permettez-moi de m'inquiéter quand même
de voir que dans la dot dans le travail
gouvernemental du moment il ya un
ministre de la justice qui est en train
de supprimer par la loi les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs délinquants
de supprimer les peines planchers de
supprimer le programme de construction
de places de prison et 2 revenant sur
les centres éducatifs fermés les oignons
construit les prisons elles sont sans
accusation volcan bien sûr on dit que
c'est justement là que se développe la
ri à la radicalisation de certains noms
là mais en tout cas condamnés de droit
commun
vous êtes d'accord avec avec cette
avance heures d'écouté c'est un constat
qui transitera par des études qui se la
prison compte d'abord les une
langoureuse et on voit bien derrière
tout cela qu'il ya une politique
pénitentiaire à poursuivre c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous souvenez sans
doute que nicolas sarkozy s'était engagé
dans sa campagne à la construction de
vingt mille places de prison
supplémentaires le programme a été
immédiatement interrompu est une des
premières décisions qui ont été prises
par les socialistes en arrivant et tout
faire pour que les détenus ne bascule
pas dans l'islamisme radical lors en
prison
bah oui mais la plupart du temps c'est
lié à des situations qui sont celles de
nos prisons aujourd'hui vous savez que
nous avons malheureusement un problème
de surpopulation carcérale et que là où
nous nous disons la réponse c'est des
constructions de places de prison les
socialistes disent il faut les remettre
en liberté est la réception des peines
de prison inférieures à deux ans la
réponse à peine cheval des alternatives
à la prison justement oui faire échapper
à ces médias sans doute enfin il ya
aussi une organisation même du but du
milieu pénitentiaire sur lequel il ya
des personnels il faut un travail
fantastique je peux en témoigner puisque
j'ai moi même ma circonscription
un centre pénitentiaire qui fonctionne
le mieux qu'il peut avec des équipes qui
sont très remarquable mais enfin il y a
la difficulté que vous évoquez est ce
que vous approuvez l'équation du
président du crif islam radical égale
nazisme
je ne peux vous dire je n'ai pas entendu
donc je peux pas la commenter ce qu'il a
d'ailleurs à l'air moi-même pardon vous
me prenez un peu de court je n'étais pas
vu cette déclaration il faut il tout cas
ce qui est sûr les ulti là dessus les
choses sont très claires
oui je le suis comme je crois tous les
français quelle que soit leur
sensibilité quelle que soit leur
religion quelles que soient leurs
convictions philosophiques ou politiques
totalement engagé dans la lutte contre
toutes ses formes d'extrémisme que je
dénonce d'ailleurs dans mon livre on
manifeste pour une droite décomplexée et
pour lequel il y a des propositions que
je formule parce que c'est un sujet
majeur et qui commence par une lutte
sans faille contre ce qu'on appelle le
communautarisme et face auquel françois
hollande un certain nombre de ses amis
ont fait oeuvre de certaines faiblesses
marque renault brille par exemple a
ouvert des créneaux spécifiques pour les
femmes dans certaines piscines de
certains quartiers de lille pendant près
de sept ans toute impunité médiatique
intellectuelle je me permets de dire que
c'est un vrai sujet alors extrêmement
chaud quand vous parlez du président du
crif mais pas entendu sa déclaration sur
le nazisme
le président du consistoire joël mergui
qui lui a appelé la communauté musulmane
dans son ensemble à se ressaisir
est-ce que vous pensez que cet appel est
fondée témoin j'ai pardon ne m'en
veuillez pas mal pas là pour faire des
commentaires et commentaires la seule
chose que je puisse dire c'est que la
mobilisation contre toutes les formes de
racisme d'antisémitisme de xénophobie
doit être une mobilisation totale et
sans faille
et sur ce point vous le savez peut-être
j'ai toujours toujours été constant dans
un appel à l'âme être alors seulement un
plaquage sur ces questions l'application
du programme de françois hollande le
chef de l'état a détaillé via son
programme pour refonder l'école vous
même dans votre livre
oui je prenais une révolution scolaire
le sucre et les opérations veut aussi
changer d'école réforme des rythmes
disparition de certaines notations
accablantes pour certains élèves des
notes qui sanctionne dit-il suppression
du redoublement est ce que ça va dans le
bon sens est ce que ce serait une bonne
chose
non c'est exactement la liste de tout ce
qu'on ne souhaitait pas qu'il proposera
donc je suis désolé mais là on est
vraiment enfin moi je suis extrêmement
inquiet question scolaire est une
question majeure pour notre société sur
laquelle qui personnel comme d'autres
j'ai beaucoup travaillé ces dernières
années
je ne retrouve évidemment rien de ses
propositions dans le programme de
françois hollande de quoi s'agit-il les
rythmes scolaires en gros rythme
scolaire il s'agit juste de décaler
quelques quelques éléments de la semaine
on revient dont c'est un éternel débat
voilà quatre jours et demi au lieu de
quatre jours très bien c'est un débat
éternel je veux juste appeler
l'attention sur une chose que françois
hollande s'est bien gardé de dire c'est
que c'est les communes qui vont devoir
payer les collectivités locales n'ont
pas le premier euro pour le faire et à
partir du moment où elles n'ont pas les
moyens de payer
françois hollande va se trouver dans un
déni de 2,2 pour mettre en oeuvre cette
réforme car la constitution est très
claire là dessus quand on transfère des
compétences on doit donner l'argent qui
va avec
première faiblesse de son raisonnement
deuxième faiblesse du raisonnement c'est
que c'est pas une réforme structurelle
ça qu'est ce qu'on attendait du
programme d'aujourd'hui par exemple que
l'on met la question de l'évaluation des
savoirs fondamentaux à l'entrée en
sixième en haut du podium
il ya aujourd'hui une préoccupation pour
tous ces enfants qui vont rentrer dans
l'univers impitoyable du collège en
passant venant du cm2 sans savoir lire
écrire et compter correctement une
priorité absolue j'ai recommandé une
évaluation à l'entrée en sixième elle
n'est toujours pas fait deuxième exemple
je préconise que le chef de
l'établissement soit le vrai patron de
son établissement qui puisse choisir ses
équipes pédagogiques et qu'ils puissent
adapter son projet c'est pas la même
chose dans le centre ville de man ou
dans un quartier sensible de tel ou tel
de telle ou telle ville rien à récupérer
enseigné la morale
on en a parlé à l'instant face aux
dérives de la société enseigné la morale
laïque ça c'est une mesure que oui je
demande juste à vérifier ce qui est
marrant parce que si morale laïque ça
veut dire qu'on doit dire du mal des
religions c'est qu'on n'a rien compris
parce que l'objectif c'est de lutter
contre l'ignorance idée certains ont
rappelé les valeurs
oui il revient très bien rappelé les
valeurs de la république c'est très bien
il faut pas craindre non plus d'ailleurs
de s'occuper aussi de la responsabilité
des parents quand les enfants sont
défaillants j'ai dans ma propre vie la
mort un problème majeur avec une école
primaire dans lequel il se trouve qu'un
certain nombre d'enfants sont absolument
un comportement inacceptable
avec des parents qui aujourd'hui ne font
pas correctement géré l n'accomplissent
pas leur mission de parents qui
acceptent à peine d'être reçus par les
professeurs ça ne peut pas continuer
comme ça je rappelle que nous avions mis
en place par exemple une loi pour lutter
contre l'absentéisme scolaire
la première décision était de la
supprimer alors qu'elle mettait en cause
la responsabilité parentale
je pense qu'encore une fois françois
hollande avance avec l'idéologique
moteur ce qui est une manière de
faciliter ça évite de ce métal avec les
camarades syndiqués rien je trouve ça
dommage
ils sont dans la rue vous a vu la cgt
aujourd'hui oui pas pour les mêmes
raisons mais en revanche du côté
d'éducation nationale tout va très très
bien quels ont été les deux grandes
décisions françois hollande voulait dit
si t'es pas gelé cité la première c'est
le tracé des recrutements massifs sans
jamais démontrer qu'on en a besoin et on
n'a pas le premier euro pour les payer
et la deuxième décision s'est rajouté
quatre jours de vacances supplémentaires
à la toussaint c'est un c'est
méconnaître la réalité des familles
d'aujourd'hui voilà quand on sait la
difficulté que nous avons aujourd'hui
que beaucoup de familles ont aujourd'hui
à occuper les enfants pendant les
vacances alors rien à sauver à part le
traité budgétaire européen
nicosie nouveautés bien sûr est ce que
quand même vous vous apprécier à leur
juste valeur les efforts du premier
ministre du président de la république
pour rassembler ni leurs engagements
j'aimerais qu'ils font ce que le maximum
de députés socialistes sur ce texte
heureux c'est déjà assez ridicule comme
ça la vérité c'est que françois hollande
dans la catégorie des impostures dont je
parlais tout à l'heure a quand même fait
campagne pendant six mois en disant si
vous m'élisez pendant un public lors pas
de tête européen parce que je négocierai
celui qui a été décidé avec entre
nicolas sarkozy angela merkel et
l'ensemble de nos partenaires européens
bon bah il est élu on a perdu quatre
mois et puis bah on revient au traité
initial voilà donc c'est une une de ces
impostures supplémentaires que l'on peut
mettre à la liste de la campagne
électorale de françois hollande ce qui
d'ailleurs est assez amusant c'est que
tout le monde tombe sur les verts qui
veulent pas le voter les communistes qui
veulent pas voter
mais je veux quand même rappeler que eux
ils sont cohérents avec les engagements
de françois hollande quoi c'est lui qui
ne l'est pas après ça pose un problème
de cohésion gouvernementale
et comme vous l'avez vu françois jean
marc ayrault avec la l'autorité qui est
la sienne a dit ça ne se passera pas
comme ça qu'il a gardé les ministres
verbist alors vous refusez le
politiquement correct la bien pensante
jean françois copé vole écrivait au fil
des pages de votre livre programme donc
mais c'est moins aujourd'hui le fonds
des arguments que vous avancez que
peut-être le style qui suscite des
remous y compris au sein de votre camp
je vous le disais là je parle du pain au
chocolat bien sûr ou bien au racisme
anti blanc certains de vos amis
d'ailleurs sont éloignés de vous sur ces
questions fondamentales selon vous vous
les mettez en avant jour après jour dans
tous les meetings avec un certain succès
vous allez pouvoir vous en parler mais
avant d'accueillir frédéric dumoulin de
l' agence france-presse
sur ces questions là et sur votre
campagne à droite tous on retrouve le
reportage de florence maurice l'un se
pose en rassembleur
l'autre est entrés en croisade racisme
anti-blanc histoire du pain au chocolat
jean françois copé veut briser les
tabous champion autoproclamé d'une
droite décomplexée
en meeting ces déclarations font
exploser l'applaudimètre mais au sein de
la droite ses anciens alliés ne ménagent
pas leurs coûts nous n'avons pas aller
sur ce terrain là ce ne sont pas nos
mots ce n'est pas notre dictionnaire et
j'ajoute que ça nous a fait mais
j'ajoute ce sont des discours de
minoritaires on doit rassembler tous ses
discours ses petites phrases sont
toxiques
elles sont dangereuses elle règle
elle altère le pacte républicain et
j'ajoute c'est une erreur d'analysé donc
naturellement je partage pas l'analyse
de jean françois dans le rétroviseur de
jean françois copé il y à nicolas
sarkozy et sa campagne offensive de
l'entre-deux tours qui lui aurait fait
grignoter quelques points alors comme
lui jean françois copé se pose en
challenger revendique le terrain et
fustige l'élite bien pensante le voit là
même qui s'affiche aux côtés de nicolas
sarkozy sur sa profession de foi et qui
selon le journal le parisien
travaillerait avec patrick buisson
le père de la stratégie très droitière
de nicolas sarkozy
la logique des campagnes électorales
c'est quand on cherche à se distinguer
de son partenaire ses adversaires et
qu'on ait conduit à durcir le ton et ça
je crois que ça ne va pas dans la bonne
direction et en général je n'ai pas
l'habitude de soutenir des choses qui ne
vont pas dans la bonne claque mais les
foudres des sages de l'ump importe peu à
jean françois copé car sa cible dans un
scrutin interne est tout autre ce sont
les adhérents du parti qu'il doit
convaincre des militants
traditionnellement plus à droite que les
sympathisants
ces quelques critiques du politiquement
correct nous sommes dans la droite
républicaine et le centre c'est ça qui a
formé l'ump nous continuons dans cette
tradition simple stratégie électorale ou
véritable durcissement idéologique
difficile à dire dans l'autre camp
pendant ce temps là françois fillon se
pose en rassembleur un candidat normal
en quelque sorte des moulins de l'
agence france-presse
nous avons toujours vos questions à jean
françois copé sur cette compétition
acharnée aux femmes berbères un peu plus
de cinq semaines de l'élection
maintenant on voit que les sondages ont
tous sont plutôt défavorables des
assauts l'ump sont majoritairement pour
françois fillon
qu'est ce qui fait que vous y croyez
encore au fond même il a raison mille
raisons en fait en vérité ces sondages
n'ont absolument aucun sens c'est bien
de les publier ça ça permet à chacun de
d'alimenter le débat et les pronostics
mais enfin il ya quand même quelque
chose qui colle pas tout à fait les sons
sont des gens qu'on appelle les
sympathisants devient un échantillon de
12 millions de français alors que ceux
qui vont voter c'est 260 milles ce sont
260 mille militants qui eux sont membres
de l'ump qui portent l'ump avec lesquels
j'ai le positionnement avec les autres
gérants
j'ai construit une relation notamment
l'occasion de cette campagne
présidentielle que je dirais personne ne
pourra jamais nous enlever c'est une
relation de deux d'engagement d'émotion
de fraternité d'armes si je puis me
permettre ce terme à travers le combat
que nous avons mené ensemble pour
soutenir nicolas sarkozy a dit elle à
monsieur grossier rabab même dans votre
propre quand vous êtes critiqué comme la
wii mais si je peux me permettre à paris
certains ténors
ben disons vous avez présenté les choses
d'une manière qui pourrait correspondre
à la thèse que vous défendiez soyons
justes jusqu'au bout lorient des fonds
non mais que vous défendiez dans votre
reportage nos méthodes et le connais pas
mal c'est juste on aurait simplement de
donner mon point de vue j'aurais pu vous
donner des noms on avait parlé de
dizaines de 6 et des ténors ou des
barytons des sopranos de l'ump qui vous
aurait dit que élus de terrain aux côtés
des militants il trouvait très bien
qu'ils se lèvent un homme pour comment
dire penser que l'avenir de la droite
n'était pas dans le dans la droite
complexé mais plutôt dans celles qui
assument une réalité du quotidien que la
thèse que je défends c'est que nous qui
sommes vous le savez et moi le premier
d'ailleurs alain juppé vous n'avez pas
passé ce passage c'est dommage la jupe
est lui-même qui n'est pas fait pour
l'indulgence et qui a dit que j'étais
irréprochable sur la question du refus
de l'alliance avec le front national
la thèse que je défends depuis toujours
et la suivante et c'est le maire de
meaux qui le dit c'est d'être et bien
entendu opposé à toute alliance avec le
front national
mais en même temps à attendre la
deuxième joue à ne pas tomber dans le
piège tendu depuis des années des années
par françois mitterrand et jean marie le
pen est repris par son fils spirituel
françois hollande avec madame le pen
c'est donc dire ce que les français
ressentent comme exaspération comme
souffrances et d'apporter une solution
il noie dans mon livre j'apporte sur
tous ces sujets de très nombreuses
solutions ceux du avec monsieur fillon
en fait qu'il est souvent perçu comme un
combat des chefs
et vous vous diriez cas vraiment vous
ici mais qui est vraiment une divergence
idéologique entre vous deux écoutez
honda borges les commentaires si je peux
me permettre ont évolué on ne dit plus
c'est ce que c'est simplement un combat
des chefs
on dit on dit quoi aujourd'hui on dit
aussi que cette deux lignes distinctes
qui sont des lignes d'ailleurs qu'ils ne
s'opposent pas forcément qu'ils sont
complémentaires au sein de l'ump
la ligne que je défends c'est celle
d'une droite et la centre droite
décomplexée c'est à dire républicain
mais également moderne ouvert aux
grandes questions de ce monde à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
à la question de la modernisation de
l'état à la baisse des déficits mais
aussi mais aussi à combattre le
politiquement correct de la gloire les
lan est encore là de la droite complexe
et un vous prêtez là le bon rayon en
crue de françois fillon voit ses je sais
pas en tout cas je fais des produits
musclées pour faire apparaître votre
rival comme un mou non non non non
écouter fossat je vous laisse au jeu
plante a quasiment vos propos non
prenons les sujets peut-être un peu
différemment
prenons des exemples concrets parce que
je crois que c'est aussi ça l'intérêt
lorsque j'ai évoqué la question de mon
engagement contre toutes les formes de
racisme et que j'ai évoqué la question
parmi ces combats à mener contre le
racisme de da raciste qui était
particulier tous et si condamnable que
les autres qu'était ce que j'avais le
raciste anti dans cette idée qu'ils
aient des quartiers où il ne fait pas
bon être une femme ou être de couleur
blanche bon que ses souffrances au
quotidien je les ai vus entendus en tant
que maire d'une ville qui n'est pas une
ville je dirais qu'ils allaient même
protection que le certains autres
quartiers de france par exemple au
centre de paris
bon j'ai pris j'ai pris une décision
cette décision c'est de le dire alors en
béton on met tomber dessus tout les
socialites toute la gauche bien pensante
procès en bon à droite isation oui mais
ça se connaît ce discours là ça n'a rien
de plus ou moins droite c'est
l'observation d'une réalité
je note que personne je dis bien
personne de ceux qui ont pris la parole
y compris pour vociférer je pense à sos
racisme n'a nié ce fait que je dénonçais
et pour cause madame belkacem a fait
pareil monsieur valls qui parle
aujourd'hui de dérapage l'a fait en son
temps
simplement la question que je pose à
tout le monde est la suivante belov
puisqu'on est d'accord sur le fait que
ça existe et que je propose des
solutions pour le combattre
est ce qu'on doit se taire c'est ça la
question et ma réponse c'est qu'on ne
doit pas se taire on doit le dire et
proposer des solutions
si vous ne le fait pas ce sera
simplement les extrêmes de gauche et de
droite qui feront c'est à dire monsieur
mélenchon à côté madame le pen de
l'autre et comme nous avons refusé
l'alliance avec le front national
alors il faut dire l'échangé vous
répondez quoi monsieur baroin qui lui
justement outre le fait qu'ils trouvent
que c'est de ces propos sont toxiques
il dit en fait que vous faites une
erreur d' analyse c'est à dire que
franck que nicolas sarkozy n'est pas
remonté en toute fin de campagne
grâce à cette pseudo droitisation mais
pour d'autres raisons donc et voulait
savoir quoi ce que je réponds à françois
marié maruao là dessus oui sur ce pas
les solutions
j'ai rien à répondre françois est
maintenant très engagé aux côtés de
françois fillon et j'imagine prêt à
construire reconstruire déconstruire des
arguments dans tous les sens pour moi là
de donner du contenu à son engagement
pour françois fillon
je n'ai donc pas de réponse à faire sur
le fond j'ai compris qu'il était donc en
désaccord avec le fait qu'on dise la
vérité sur le relais sur le terrain et
qu'il était donc en désaccord avec le
fait qu'on puisse proposer des solutions
c'est son choix pour tout vous dire je
ne le reconnais pas complètement sur le
racisme anti-blanc certains vous avez
même sorti des témoignages de gauche
ancien à aller dans votre sens norme en
france sur le petit pain au chocolat
c'est qu'on arrache au à l'enfant
pendant la période de ramadan là et
c'est trés guareh il très content et le
projet du tout mais mais j'ai bossé au
bout de ses limites ou contestées ça a
été exactement le même processus
le même c'est à dire que personne n'a
contesté les faits personne vous pouvez
regarder personne mais monsieur ayrault
qui nous faire la leçon
chez vos confrères de france inter le
dimanche matin j'ai été amené à lui
répondre dans un meeting quelques heures
après est venu dire oui ces phénomènes
peuvent exister mais heureusement qu'il
l'a reconnu puisque tout le monde le
sait c'est du même acabit que ce
restaurateur de marseille passé à tabac
pendant l'été parce qu'il avait le
malheur de servir des repas pendant la
journée passée à tabac
c'est dans la presse ont la vérité qui a
derrière tout cela c'est quoi c'est que
pendant le monsieur ayrault finalement
ne nie pas que ces faits existent eh
bien nous retombons sur le même problème
que ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
pour le racisme anti blanc faut-il ou
non le dit
et encore une fois je le répète si on le
dénonce comme je le fais en tant que
républicain c'est proposer des solutions
la solution elle existe elle est dans la
des ghettos isation je les fais à meaux
en cassant les tours en mettant à la
place des immeubles de quatre étages à
taille humaine mix en accession à la
propriété logement social
là où il n'y avait que des logements
sociaux en mettant des caméras vidéo
surveillance des policiers municipaux
une zone franche pour détaxer les
entreprises qui embauchent les gens du
quartier
en mettant la culture du sport et de la
santé
et ben qu'est ce qui se passe à la fin
vous n'avez plus le même quartier donc
au lieu d'interdire la parole et le
témoignage de gens qui comme moi veulent
reconstruire la droite et le centre
droit de demain en disant les choses et
en proposant des solutions
on est dans une logique de dire non il
faut lui interdire de parler c'est
tellement mieux qu'ils parlent pas assez
on est on a un bon mot pour ça ça mots
codés
c'est le mot droitisation dire que celui
qui dit la vérité avec des propositions
non c'est juste parce qu'il est temps
droitisation en campagne comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure mais quand on dit
rien et bien moi je veux dire dans cette
affaire-là monde est mon arbitrage il
est rendu depuis bien longtemps
parce que celui dont je parce que la
ville dont je suis l'élu elle sait ce
que c'est au quotidien la souffrance
quelle que soit d'ailleurs les origines
les sensibilités il à l'heure de
pauvreté que l'agent square c'est une
réponse c'est une réponse
assumez vous avez encore des tabous
guillemets à combattre enfin écoutés
après le après le pain au chocolat le
racisme anti blanc et auvillar ya
d'autres choses et ce exclusivement de
ne prenez pas en mauvaise part mais
cette manie qu'ont à paris mais ça s'est
tellement c'est tellement parisien de
vouloir absolument nous faire des procès
en sincérité des hommes politiques
pourquoi est ce que là la seule
explication qu'on pourrait donner au
fait que je parle de tout ça dans un
livre c'est que je suis en campagne pour
l'ump mais ça fait des années que je le
dis des années que je le raconte en 1999
j'écris la lys là puisque je n'ai pas
appris et l'ena où je raconte mon
parcours de mère m'a découverte de
jeunes mères qui voit ce qu'est la
réalité du quotidien
hélas ces quinze ans après je dis qu'on
a fait on a apporté des réponses et
qu'on y est arrivé
donc plutôt que de dire avant elle fait
ça parce qu'il est encore pas est ce que
une fois on peut accepter que les hommes
politiques soient sincères lorsqu'ils
disent que vous parlez souvent à nicolas
aussi est-ce que vous avez l'occasion
depuis cette polémique de l'un d'eux lui
en parler puisque lui aussi pendant la
campagne présidentielle s'était vu
reprocher d'aller trop vers la droite
qu'est ce que vous en avez parler ou pas
enfin pas de là spécialement mais encore
une fois cette histoire de dettes trop
vers la droite ou vers la gauche ça veut
dire écoutez on va y aller à l'envers ça
veut donc dire que si on ne voit pas le
problème est que si d'autres banques
n'acceptent pas de le dénoncer
donc on va vers la gauche donc on est
dans la gauchisation donc vous ne vous
me demander d'arbitrer entre
droitisation et gauchisation vous voyez
comme tout ce pardon ne prenez pas mal
oui comme tout ça est absurde
le vrai débat il est de savoir face à
cette vérité est ce qu'on a le courage
de dire des choses ou de ne pas les dire
et pour ce qui me concerne je ne cadrais
jamais et personne je le dis très
amicalement personne ne m'empêchera de
dire ce que les uns et les autres de nos
compatriotes 10 et nous demandent de
résoudre
sinon ce sera la place aux extrêmes et
tout ce qu'il me faut ce petit procès
sympathique la droite droitisation etc
il oublie juste un petit détail c'est
que s'ils font national est seul à
parler de ces questions sans apporter de
réponse vient ce rythme à 6 ans ils
tendront à cet endroit recouvre la vie
qui ne le croit vous pensez que c'est le
meilleur rempart face au front national
de c'est le meilleur rempart et pim face
au front national
et face à cette collusion que tout le
monde connaît entre la gauche et
l'extrême droite
parce que eux sont totalement rassemblée
1e et ils ont fait une alliance sans se
poser aucune question avec l'extrême
gauche de mélenchon qui n'a rien à
envier à l'extrême droite de jean marie
le pen et nous on a dit notre honneur
c'est de ne pas faire d'alliance avec
l'extrême droite
mais en contrepartie je le dis jamais je
ne demanderai à mes et à nos électeurs
et nos militants de voter pour le parti
socialiste allié de l'extrême gauche car
cette espèce de pseudo front républicain
n'est absolument pas une réalité
politique
c'est simplement une manière pour garder
le pouvoir à n'importe quel prix
aujourd'hui il n'ya de voir les jeux
marine le pen envisage des accords aux
municipales 1
elle sait que la base de l'ump vous le
savez une partie des élus y sont
favorables pour sauver une mairie vous
me développement les choses sont très
claires elles le sont d'ailleurs pour
toute notre famille politique il n'y
aura pas d'alliance électorale avec le
front national
dernière question frédéric tellement
parlé nicolas sarkozy en fait
on voit que vous faites beaucoup
référence à lui à la foison sur la
couverture de votre livre dans votre
profession de foi et dans vos discours
très très fréquemment
est ce que vous estimez être plus proche
de son à l'étagé de son bilan que je
prends ce fillon coude et moi en tout
cas je suis pas très doué pour la
publicité comparative la seule chose que
je puisse vous dire c'est que j'ai
clairement inscrit mon engagement sur le
chemin tracé par nicolas sarkozy je les
dis sans ambiguïté je considère que il a
beaucoup oeuvré pour la france que même
si nous avons ici ou là de temps en
temps des désaccords connu il ne reste
pas moins qu'il a fait preuve dans cette
campagne où il a été l'objet d'attaqués
absolument inouïe d'une violence
incroyable d'un courage et d'une
solidité qui ont forcé mon admiration et
qui m'ont amené très clairement à dire
que je serai à ses côtés voilà et que
dans ce contexte la philosophie qui est
la sienne même si mon tempérament est
différent du sien sur certains sujets ou
mon point de vue et mon expérience
puisque je suis moi maire de meaux donc
ce n'est pas évidemment le même parcours
que le sien il n'en reste pas moins que
je les dis je me suis inscrit sur le
chemin qu'il avait tracée par les
philosophies faisant vous allez même
plus loin que lui sur certains points
comme la m
ou oui c'est vrai mais bon encore une
fois les temps changent et je crois que
de cette nouvelle époque conduit assez
naturellement à poser des questions
claires la mc quoi l'aide médicale
d'état c'est celle qui est versé grâce à
100% couverte c'est une couverture de
soins pardon à 100% pour les pour les
ceux qui sont en situation illégale dans
notre pays bon il me semble quelque
chose qui tourne pas rond dans le même
temps vous avez des millions de français
qui sont au dessus des minima sociaux et
qui n'arrivent pas à financer
correctement leurs soins de lunettes
dedans auditifs bien et donc j'ai
proposé que l'on supprime la partie de
l'aide médicale d'état qui ne
correspondent pas l'urgence absolue ou
au soir les encore et qu'on le
transférait sur un fonds qui serait
dédié à l'aide de à la prise en charge
des soins pour mon ce2 qui habite en
france qui sont français ou bien
étrangers en situation régulière et qui
ainsi pourrez accéder à une prise en
charge meilleur pour des soins qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas bien couvert et
votre ami christian jacob lui propose
une loi pour lutter contre les fraudes
et dérapages budgétaires de cette aide
médicale un mot sur le qatar est ce que
ça vous gêne le voir le qatar vouloir
investir dans les banlieues on a
beaucoup parlé très content et moi j'ai
dit là dessus plus repris je n'ai jamais
été choqué qu'il y ait des
investissements étrangers en france
après la vraie question c'est s'assurer
de la traçabilité et de la finalité
donc vigilance mais en même temps ne
faisons pas un procès d'intention
systématique
voilà merci fédérer était alors taux
n'est pas politique et dans votre livre
jean françois copé je le disais tout à
l'heure vous ai parlé de vous de votre
parti pris positif vous avez montré que
vous étiez positif quand on parle de
femmes il le fallait parce que si on
vous écoutez voir sortie dépresseurs
vous parle également de votre histoire
familiale et avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud alexandre aquino s'est arrêté
avec quelques témoins qui vont vous
intéressé de très près sur ces quelques
pages c'est une histoire déjà évoqué en
aparté et qui introduit le manifeste
pour une droite décomplexée un héritage
qui serait à l'origine de l'engagement
politique de jean-françois copé
cette histoire est celle de son père et
de ses grands parents juifs immigrés
roumains et résistant quel joli par des
justes à aubusson pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale une histoire familiale
dans la grande histoire
c'était dans la matinée ont été avertis
mon père a eu juste le temps de
descendre à l'étagé du dessous pour
demander à une voisine qu'on ne
connaissait pour ainsi dire pas et qui
était la femme d'un tapissier de bien
vouloir nous accueillir chez elle parce
que dans quelques dans la demi-heure qui
vient en principe y aura les ss qui vont
arriver pour nous prendre
et avec une simplicité extraordinaire
elle a dit mais monsieur vous êtes chez
vous descendez ce qui est des fumant moi
cette phrase m'a toujours marqué j'étais
gosse mais et le sage et transmis
toujours à jean-françois pour lui
montrer ce que pouvait être un être
humain dans sa qualité dans sa bonté de
se passer jean françois copé qui en
avoir puisé
un amour pour la france et l'évidence
d'un engagement politique
ça donne un pouvoir une rare
d'engagement et une roche d'engagement
sous ses formes
mais c'est probablement ce qui est
arrivé à jean françois copé c'est à dire
le garage comprendre la motivation va
s'engager le plaisir aussi de s'engager
peut-être même parfois le plaisir de la
bagarre d'entités difficile à définir
des immigrés juifs
des termes qu'il n'évoque pas
directement préférant reprendre les mots
de nicolas sarkozy petit français de
sang mêlé voilà à perrine tarneaud nous
a rejoint jean françois copé françois
perin jean françois copé a lancé
pourquoi vous aimez la bagarre en
écoutant brice unique
oui enfin je n'aurais pas repris le mot
de bagarres non l'engagement oui
l'engagement il a tellement l'engagement
pour mon pays que j'explique d'ailleurs
non mais nous avons été éduqués par mes
parents je dis nous parce que c'est
aussi le cas de ma soeur et de mon frère
cadet dans l'amour de la france dans
l'idée que l'on doit à la france que
nous sommes vivants si je puis dire
parce qu'il est des français qui ont
péri de leurs vies sauvées d'autres
français des justes parmi les nations
qui ont même titre que les résistants
que les maquisards ont aussi fait que la
france est ce pays magnifique et que
nous aimons malgré malgré des moments
tragiques de son histoire malgré les
errements malgré les difficultés et
c'est quelque chose que je porte en moi
comme une flamme et lorsque gm ont
raconté des buts 28 mai dont vous parlez
peu de temps vous avez peut-être parler
jusque là en fait oui parce que les
circonstances ne s'y prêtait pas
forcément vous savez il n'y a pas de
raison particulière de raconter ça des
gens que ça n'intéresse pas forcément
alain faucon sans s'y prêterait tout
simplement parce que j'ai décidé de
m'engager dans une
campagne aux côtés des militants de
l'ump pour leur proposer de m'engager
pour eux pour notre famille politique et
que j'ai pensé utile que à ce moment
précis il y est aussi un rendez-vous
d'authenticité
ça veut dire que vous avez besoin de
communiquer peut-être différemment alors
sur votre image sur votre personne ne
sait pas là dedans je sais comme tout à
l'heure pour la savourer ce qu'on fait
de la chair et de la surenchère non non
je pense que ces jours ci c'est juste je
viendrai mettre des militants vous
l'avez dit sous la forme et
communication etc
non je crois qu'il faut se dire les
choses très simplement je pense qu'il y
a des moments dans la vie qui sont des
rendez vous de vérité et d'authenticité
je pense que les gens en réalité elle ne
cherche pas tellement des photos de vous
dans votre cuisine avec la nappe à
carreaux rouge et blanc et les enfants
qui gazouille ça c'est la vie privée en
tout cas toujours non le passé jamais
non jamais non justement j'ai toujours
été extrêmement attention votre mère
femmes n'ont pas besoin de vous abonnez
vous
c'est la seule fois mais pour le reste
vous n'avez jamais vu mes enfants en
photo sauf peut-être développe des
photos volées que j'ai d'ailleurs
immédiatement condamné autant que j'ai
pu le faire mais j'ai toujours protégé
ma vie familiale toujours et là dessus
j'ai été d'autant plus attentifs que
pour moi ce que les gens attendent c'est
plutôt comment vous dire
un rendez-vous vraiment où les gens
veulent savoir ce qui ce qui brille en
vous voilà ce qui fait que vous avez
dans le regard
l'envié de les servir voilà de servir
votre pays c'est ça qui doit faire la
différence
est ce que ça veut dire que jusque là
vous avez eu l'impression d'avoir été
trop caricaturé alors peut-être bon la
caricature malheureusement dans cette
société hyper médiatisée elle est notre
pain quotidien
je suis marie dont on ne parlait de moi
de manière tellement par exemple des
formes et que la vraie de vaud où j'ai
mis les gants monsieur emile exemple
on explique que ce que je sais tout sur
tout je suis arrogant que jamais plein
des comme ça
bon la vérité lui dit vous avez plus
sympa que votre père oui voilà oui oui
ça c'était vraiment pas bien de la part
de ce médecin
est-ce que ça a pu vous poussez vous
corriger à la remarque du médecin mara
je parle pas du luxe
et les deux ne veut retenir de le
corriger aussi d'ailleurs
les caricatures oui mais la caricature
en même temps elle est aussi liée à ce
que l'on est donc il faut il faut il
faudra un travail sur soi même il faut
bien sûr mais vous savez je crois
beaucoup au fait d'avoir 2 dead de vivre
aussi avec des interrogations plus
qu'avec des certitudes
il faut qu'on ait des convictions mais
voilà se remette en question sans cesse
et pour ça y'a rien de mieux que le
suffrage universel c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai toujours été attaché à ma terre de
mots la ville dont je suis le meilleur
car c'est une ville difficile avec une
population qui est une des plus
mauvaises de france et qui donc est
extrêmement exigeantes à l'égard de deux
de ses élus et c'est pour ça que je me
dis parfois quand on change de deux
circonscriptions
c'est pas quelque chose que je ferais
moi voilà donc à qui pensez-vous
les eschois attendait c'est un choix et
blick donc sinon je n'aurais pas parlé
mais moi ce qui me concerne je suis
vraiment dans cette idée qui que des
coups comme disait jacques chirac en
politique un autre avant tout car il
faut prendre ses responsabilités et
qu'il faut les assumer
quand c'est difficile comme quand c'est
plus facile et puis peut-être puisque
vous parlez de jacques chirac dont je
parle beaucoup parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a un qui nous a vraiment contribué à
merci à ma formation et à mon engagement
au service de mon pays pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup de respect j'avais retenu une
de ses formules 10 et un chef c'est fait
pour chez fait voilà et quand on dirige
un grand parti politique je peux
témoigner tous les jours qu'on ne peut
pas avoir simplement la tête dans les
étoiles en attendant qu'on vous apporte
votre destin sur un plateau c'est tous
les jours aux côtés de ses amis
militants pour trouver les meilleures
solutions possibles voudront vendre le
coeur des français un élu de paris comme
françois fillon donc enfin annoncé en ce
qui me concerne ce n'est certainement
pas le choix que je ferai la violence en
politique est parfois insupportable
c'est ce que vous dites aussi dans votre
livre où il souhaite construire une
carapace vous parlez pas
reconquérir cationiques parfois vous
vous dites que c'est vous une prise de
distance par rapport à la violence
n'était pas rendu compte mais je me suis
aperçu très souvent en fait quand
j'étais dans une situation qui me
blessais il pouvait m'arriver de le
masquer par un sourire voilà mais en
même temps ce qu'on vit en ce moment est
très éclairant regarder cette campagne
interne qui est une campagne qui se
terminera bien puisque le 19 novembre au
matin par définition tout le monde se
retrouvera et c'est mes copains copains
autant qu'on peut l'être mais en tout
cas
soucieux de l'intérêt général en tout
cas c'est l'esprit qui m'anime si les
militants me font confiance et me
reconduire dans mes fonctions soutien se
construiront mais en même temps pas
totalement quand même en tout cas pour
ce qui me concerne moi qui suis
tellement attachés à l'amitié tellement
attaché à la fidélité en amitié
ce moment est un moment de vérité voilà
je vais pas vous dire le contraire mais
je vais pas passer plus de temps avec
ceux qui me déçoivent qu'avec ceux qui
au contraire sont à mes côtés et
prennent des risques en étant un des
côtés puisque si j'en crois les sondages
il en est un qui a la tête dans les
étoiles et l'autre qui a les pieds dans
le gaz de schiste donc après tous ceux
qui sont avec moi ça montre quelque part
un un vrai courage et qui elle reflet de
l'engagement militant car l'homme la
sincérité m'oblige à vous dire je suis
tous les jours en meeting et que je suis
tous les jours
bouleversé par le soutien des militants
qui est extraordinaire et qu'il reflet
de l'engagement à 1000% qui a été le
mien dans cette campagne présidentielle
aux côtés de nicolas sarkozy
alors vous parliez d'amitié en politique
et aussi de déceptions on a un
partenariat avec orange et leur
application tivi tchèque en à une
question de ma bien est-ce que vous avez
été blast blessé par le ralliement de
françois baroin à françois fillon à
titre politique non à titre personnel
oui un gros coup dur enfin à titre
personnel oui bien sûr quand vous êtes
dans les dix ans en tout cas je pas
parler pour les autres mais pour moi à
titre personnel je peux vous dire les
choses très simplement jamais jamais je
n'ai manqué de ma vie à un ami jamais
parce que je ne suis pas construit comme
ça peut-être que ça un lien aussi avec
eux l'éducation que j'ai reçue de mes
parents mais pour moi la parole donnée
la crédibilité d'une signature d'un
engagement c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important ça ne veut pas
dire que parfois on n'est pas des choix
à faire des choix déchirants via la mort
quand on parle de politique avait tout à
fait raison des orientations rêver tout
à fait raison mais je vous dis en ce qui
me concerne je n'ai jamais manqué à ma
parole
voilà et que si je devais le faire ce
serait sur la base d'une explication
profonde qui serait justifié par une
rupture absolue sur des sujets vitaux
nous en sommes très loin
voilà vous êtes quand même un sarkozyste
fraîchement convertis du coup est ce que
votre sarkozysme et crédible non je
pense pas c'est pas comme ça que je me
définirais non non j'ai fait le choix
vrais opposants groupe à lui à loos ump
à l'assemblée avait raison comme c'est
un peu chef de file les indépendants par
rapport à ce que je suis toujours ne
vous y trompez pas je suis toujours j'ai
mon histoire il a la sienne nous avons
certes quelques points communs mais en
même temps les différences majeures et
puis écoutez il a été président de la
république je suis son cadet ben voilà
il ya des différences entre nous oui
bien sûr mais en même temps je vous dis
les choses
j'ai été je je le dis je l'assument j'ai
été très impressionné par la solidité
dont il a fait preuve dans cette
campagne un moment présidentielle à un
moment où j'ai vu tant de personnalités
à qui il avait tant donné qu'ils ont
lâché disons les choses comme elles sont
comme d'ailleurs nous avons retrouvé à
travers les droits d'inventaire les
livres les tribunes sortie après le 6
mai je n'ai pas était de ceux là
jusqu'à la dernière minute aujourd'hui
je les fais d'autant plus avec d'autant
plus de patients que je voyais ces
milliers et milliers de françaises et de
français militants engagés à nos côtés
et du coup vous allez impression un peu
aujourd'hui qu'au tour de nicolas
sarkozy c'est un peu le bal des
tartuffes pro oui je suis papa sait pas
forcément ce boisé président et
ensevelis sous les compliments rock soit
toujours écouté pas toujours il ya aussi
les prises de distance très intéressante
à noter une question sur la loi sur la
limitation du cumul des mandats vous
êtes contre oui bien sûr mais bien sûr
ces jeux vous dire c'est une belle
hypocrisie tout cela changerait la
démission je pense que la démocratie
je connais pourquoi les conclusions de
spam et la démocratie française a ceci
de positif qu'elle permet
h aux élus d'avoir un mandat local et un
mandat national c'est très très bien
un député par le d'autant plus utilement
l'assemblée nationale qu' il est le
maire d'une ville où on lui raconte les
problèmes du quotidien ou doit les
résoudre
un député qui n'est pas élu qui n'est
pas maire de sa ville
mais qu'est ce qui va lui arriver demain
plus personne n'ira le voir parce que
c'est le maire de la ville il vient voir
pour les foyers logements et d'emplois
ou de sécurité s'est jamais le député
alé minutes pour deux questions qu un
député qui exerce aussi une profession
réglementée est ce que ça on doit
limiter très réglementé comme un avocat
par exemple d'accord à vous écouter ça
c'est autre chose
la question n'est plus générale est ce
que l'on doit interdire aux députés
d'avoir une autre vie professionnelle si
on ne le fait pas et bien permettez moi
de dire qu'il n'y aura plus que 100 % de
fonctionnaires sauf à considérer qu'on
ne doit pas être également fonctionnaire
est ce que les socialistes vont prendre
ce risque donc pas su voir derrière tout
ça est très poli très rapidement si la
loi sur le mariage homosexuel passe vous
à les marier des couples homosexuels
mais moi je suis opposé je les dis très
clairement que non au mariage homosexuel
je les dis en même temps je souhaite que
les propos des uns et des autres ne soit
pas un vrai côté on va déjà temps de
voir celle-ci avait voté parce que bien
attention tout ça me paraît tellement
mal rédigée qu'il y a de quoi en
débattre il ya une majorité de gauche
pour le traité budgétaire européen à
l'assemblée nationale c'est un test
réussi pour françois hollande
ah bah écoutez c'est surtout comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure une belle
hypocrisie de la part de quelqu'un qui a
fait campagne devant les français
allaient ainsi les têtes et lui auraient
pas traités européens
merci jean françois euvé merci perrine
bonsoir à tous
et la semaine prochaine c'est jean louis
borloo qui sera notre invité bonsoir
je vous propose de commencer par la
stratégie de françois hollande alors à
l'époque où il vivait avec ségolène
royal s'était le plus discret du couple
et récemment et bien il a décidé de
présenter sa nouvelle compagne c'était
dans gala valérie est la femme de ma vie
annonce et il élégamment en octobre
dernier
mais attention pas question de poser
officiellement avec sa nouvelle compagne
c'est peut-être un détail mais pour les
vous allez voir que ça veut dire
beaucoup écouté le sur le plateau de
france 2 on va dire un mot des primaires
avec d'abord une image qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir de vous c'est cette
semaine dans un magazine people comme on
dit où vous apparaissez avec votre
compagne vous poser à ses côtés
pourquoi cette décision parce que c'est
très inhabituel
est ce qu'il faut en passer par là
lorsqu'on veut se présenter face aux
français non ce n'est pas une photo
posée nous étions ensemble à la rochelle
la photo a été prise
elle est publiée voilà c'est tout vous
donné l'interview aussi je suis dans une
vie nouvelle heureuse
voilà il faut bien cachés mais en même
temps rien exhibé rien à cacher rien
exhibé à vous approuvez ma femme c'est
très subtil jeu de sel à ce qu'on me dit
tout à l'heure
oui dit la même chose que vous je trouve
vraiment à double tranchant la photo
elle a été prise malgré lui en avant
mais la déclaration c'est la femme de ma
vie moi là où je pars à cette occasion
oui avec laquelle il a quand même eu
quatre enfants suit alors la réaction
des enfants s'est interrogé les femmes
autres vous autour de vous c'est
vraiment extrêmement choquant bouleversé
la femme que j'aime la femme de ma vie
on efface d'un coup les quatre enfants
ben c'est pas très malin parce que c'est
très contre-productif donc c'est très
maladroit sur la phrase
et pourtant il n'a pas posé un pour lui
ce qui était important c'était pas faire
de photos et finalement se polarise sur
la maladresse a posé il a décidé de
s'afficher avec une femme de dire c'est
la femme de sa vie ce qui est
effectivement je trouve très maladroit
parce qu'il voulait absolument se mettre
dans la roue de la présidentielle et il
faut qu'il arrête avec cette image d'
homme volage qui a trompé ségolène royal
et ils y arrivent très bien par contre
la déclaration et d'une maladresse
énorme maladresse pour les femmes
effectivement qu'ils peuvent le trouvera
il lui faut en même temps c'est la femme
de ma vie ça veut dire que dans votre
sens il va dans le sens de ce que vous
dites il va se stabiliser maintenance
est venu c'est le message politique
c'est le message politique
toujours ce qu'on dit malgré tout à la
deuxième ou la troisième du moment qu'on
leur dise donc c'est assez honnête de
dire publiquement on est journaliste
jusqu'au bout c'est à dire même si un
jour je perds ma carte de presse
je pense que je mourrais journalistes
mais comme vous je pense donc en étant
journaliste est si proche évidemment de
françois hollande
est-ce que vous recevez des conseils
pour trouver la bonne distance avec tout
ce qui se passe en ce moment
non j'ai appris des conseils peut-être
pas mais j'ai appris moi me détendre un
peu parce qu'effectivement je ne suis
pas passé de l'autre côté mais j'ai un
pied de chaque côté donc quand on a un
pied de chaque côté on est en
déséquilibre
voilà c'est plus compliqué donc en tout
cas je suis beaucoup plus à l'aise
depuis que je n'ai plus mon émission
politique puisque j'en avais une sur
direct 8
même trois successives donc j'ai décidé
de l'arrêter de moi même et ça a été
finalement un grand soulagement
j'ai appris à me détendre un peu dit
elle que pensez vous de cette confidence
serge hefez c'est une vraie confidences
dire ça montre quelqu'un quel point elle
s'est rendu compte à quel point il était
crispé et ça se voyait elle était très
mal dans cette position de se retrouver
comme ça brutalement en position de
femme de on sent bien qu'elle n'a pas
envie de ça d'abord ils sont pas mariés
alors oui souligne pas assez mais je
crois que c'est une c'est une différence
fondamentale pas l'intention de ça il a
très bien mais ça ça ça repose la
question de la légitimité c'est à dire
que si en plus ils ne sont pas mariés et
qu'il devient président de la république
ça va être une première dans l'histoire
de france d'avoir un couple illégitime
comme ça à la tête de l'état donc elle a
raison de dire que lé les pieds et à
pied à pied de chaque côté et
effectivement elle représente ces femmes
ces nouvelles femmes
on va dire qui jusqu'au bout vont se
battre pour leur carrière pour leur
personnalité pour leur identité sachant
que c'est pas simple
c'est pas simple quand on est à 7 c'est
une personnalité profondément dual
valérie trierweiler
à l'image de tout ce que nous voyons
d'elle depuis tout à l'heure et de tout
ce que nous voyons tout le temps elle
est en effet un pied d'un côté un pied
de l'autre mais je crois que ça
correspond à une personnalité intime
d'accord c'est donc ce n'est pas
vraiment très rassurant d'accord elle
n'arrive pas à choisir
parce que finalement elle est comme ça
elle veut tout à la fin je sais que
c'est possible ça serge hefez d'être
comme ça pour c'est possible d'être
ambivalence est beau utile de vouloir
une chose et son contraire mais enfin il
ya bien un moment où la vie vous amène à
faire un certain nombre de choix nous ne
laisserons pas des caïds s'installer
dans les quartiers de grenoble devenu à
la fois leur proie et leurs repères et
je lutterai contre tous les trafics
toutes les mafias pas plus que je
n'accepte la délinquance financière
la fraude fiscale
pas plus
je le tolère qu'un petit caïd avec sa
bande mais une cité en coupe réglée et
fassent vivre à ses habitants un enfer à
tout cela à tout cela aux délinquants
financiers aux fraudeurs aux petits
caïds
je les avertis ceux qui ont pu croire
que la loi ne les concernait pas le
prochain président les prévient la
république
oui la république vous rattrapera un
petit caïd avec sa bande mettre une cité
en coupe réglée lui faire vivre un enfer
comme ça longtemps on a l'impression de
réécouter des discours de nicolas
sarkozy alors on se doute bien que c'est
que françois hollande ya pensé à ces
références enfin on le voit mal faire ça
par hasard alors de montmagny affres
selon vous